Noble ones. I'm back. I am back indeed.
Wait, I need I need a prop about that.
As it was highly requested in my
community, today we're going to talk
about the channel called Lady of the
Library, specifically about a recent
video on the whole debacle that is
Nolan's interpretation of the Odyssey.
As you can see, latest video from 4 days
ago. The Odyssey discourse is
embarrassing, she says. You know what's
funny? I actually agree with that. I do
think the Odyssey discourse is
embarrassing. The only thing is that I
believe we think it's embarrassing for
different reasons. Chinsia, Cynthia, I
don't know how you pronounce it, but if
I can use your name, I hope you don't
mind. And that is not the only video
that she made on the Odyssey because
four months ago, she actually made a
video called We Need to Talk about
Nolan's Odyssey trailer. Yeah, tell me
about it. Anyways, before we jump into
it, I just want to say this very
quickly. Okay, today I actually going to
disagree with her quite a bit because
we're going to focus on two things.
Thing number one, what counts as an
embarrassing critique when it comes to
the Odyssey, and what counts as an
appropriate critique of said work,
debauchery. No, l. But mostly, we're
going to address Emily Wilson's
translation of the Odyssey, which Lady
of the Library Defends. And I'm going to
attack. With that being said, please
don't go harass her, okay? Be nice in
the comments because I just want to say
it. I kind of like her channel. I like
her presentation style. She sounds like
a very intelligent, very learned woman.
I appreciate her passion for the
classics given she's very leftwing and
usually leftwingers in the context of
history and culture piss me off. But I'm
going to try I'm going to try and be
nice. I'm going to try and be
respectful. Okay, I'll do my best. I
mean, I can't promise anything. I'm
Italian. I mean, keeping it cool with
liberals for me. I'm joking. My gosh.
Already all offended. Offended.
Order a pizza. No, but I mean it. I mean
it. I'm going to try. I mean it. Okay.
I'm gonna try and be nice
>> from the typical white voice of power
employed by most of
>> Oh my gosh. white voice of power, guys.
I don't know how to do it. I don't know
how to do it. I don't know how to not
cringe when I watch leftwing creators.
What do I do? What do I do?
Just attack her arguments. I'm not going
to attack her. She has every freedom to
think whatever she wants. So, please
don't go and attack her. Let's show how
people with different ideas when it
comes to social issues, economics,
politics, interpretation of history, and
the classics can still be decent.
Without further ado, that was a lot of
further ado, actually, but let's go.
>> This video is sponsored by Squarespace,
the all-in-one website platform for
entrepreneurs to stand out and succeed
online. Not the actual heck. Everyone
seems to be ruining the Odyssey, and it
seems as though people out there are
doing everything they can to trick
>> that would be uh that would be Nolan
ruining the Ollie Odyssey. Nolan, first
and foremost,
>> Nolan, any of us who are in classics or
ancient history and they're doing a
really good job of it.
I do not think I can hide the fact that
I'm going to be really sassy in this
video because I'm feeling extra sassy.
And
>> you do sound a little sassy.
>> It was going to start off as like sort
of a little innocent video critiquing
the latest Nolan trailer for The
Odyssey. Uh, and that's sort of been
usurped by my feelings of hearing other
people talk about it online and
particularly one video on here on
YouTube that has over 1.7 million views.
>> That's as mongled, isn't it? That's
that's Wait, wait, wait, wait. I need to
for the investigation to be th because I
don't think she's going to say it. Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. Oh, DCongold.
I got to Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. That's
Assong. All right. That's Osmong. All
right. 1.7 million. You might as well
say it. I'm going to pronounce it the
Italian way. You might as well say it at
this point. Anyways, whatever your
channel, let's go.
>> And it spews absolute nonsense. Like the
biggest nonsense I've ever heard.
>> A bit like what Nolan is doing. Am I
right?
>> May I emphasize to an audience of 1.7
million people who have actually
regurgitated that nonsense in my own
YouTube channel comment section. We're
not having it. We're not having it. How
do people have the audacity
>> that's my audio auditing software
>> to spew such nonsense so confidently
seriously. So it's kind of two parters.
I'm first going to address the the
silliness, the melodrama, the lies um
that was spread by a single video here
on YouTube in their analysis of the
trailer and then I'm going to talk about
my own analysis of the trailer. Good.
But as I'm writing this script, I
realized that news has evolved because
we have heard rumors that there has been
new castations. I believe we have Lupita
Nyongo who has been confirmed as Helen
of Troy but also Clive Estra.
>> I am so okay. I am so looking forward to
see what she's going to say about this
because here's the thing. As I will
demonstrate in a second, the lady of the
library has been critical when it comes
to the older trailer for the Odyssey.
And generally speaking, I agree with her
when she flipped about the armor, the
Batman arm. Totally. Yeah, 100%. At that
point, I think it doesn't even matter.
Left, right, up, or down, whatever. We
can all agree that that armor is awful.
But she also has complained about skin
tone.
She has.
>> Now, speaking of looking organic to the
world in which they exist, let's talk
about um the least looking Mediterranean
cast choices I've ever seen,
particularly the main trio. Uh whilst
they're all brilliant actors, I'm sure
uh they sort of personify the issues
that we have with the British Museum and
their Elgen marbles rather than the
Pathon marbles. They sort of look like
sterilized versions and look very out of
place.
>> I mean, Adysius does not look like a man
who has been exposed to the
Mediterranean climate in a war for 10
years followed
>> Yeah. So his skin is too white, right?
That's the reason why they don't look
their parts. the skin is too white
>> by three years at sea under the same
climate followed by seven years stranded
on a Mediterranean island. And like
>> I mean I spent my whole life in my
Mediterranean island and I mean
>> Penelopey and Tmicus don't look like
they remotely belong there. Like when
did they last see the sun? It's not like
it's Victorian England where people hide
away to keep their skin pale.
>> You see she's complaining about white
skin. What is she going to say about
this? I'm very curious your opinion cuz
you have complained about skin tone
being too white. So what are you going
to do now?
>> I think Lupita Nyongo would have been a
better Penelope than Anne Hatheraway.
>> I'm confused. Lup. Okay. She hasn't
mentioned once that Helen of Troy is
black.
She can't mention it. Her audience won't
forgive it. She has to pretend it's not
even a thing. Ironically, Assassin's
Creed Odyssey, a video game, does a much
better job at showcasing authenticl
looking Greek people.
>> To be honest, that's a black woman. How
is this an authentic looking Greek? Oh,
maybe she's talking about him. But
again, I think you're st Yes, some
Mediterranean people have a darker
complexion, but a lot of us don't. A lot
of us are very white, and you can see
this in all iconography. It's not just a
modern thing. You can look at the
iconography and it is what it is.
>> People than this film. Uh, at least they
look like they have been in the sun. And
honestly, it would have been nice to
have some Greek or Mediterranean actors
in this film.
>> So, I agree with this statement. That's
lovely. Okay, I agree with this
statement. But you are complaining about
the white skin a lot. So now someone has
to beg the question, if having too white
a skin makes you an inappropriate
casting for ancient Greeks, then how on
green planet Earth doesn't being a black
African make you inappropriate as a
casting choice? Obviously that follows
logical sense, but she can't say it. She
can complain about the skin is too white
all she wants because her audience is
clearly left-wing. I mean, she makes
videos talking about the rise of
paganism and the far right. So, which is
her choice. By the way, I respect the
freedom, but clearly she is left-wing
and she acrews left-wing audiences by
the way her commentary is structured and
the type of videos that she chooses to
make. Thus, however, this also means
that she cannot complain the same way.
She can complain about the white skin
all she wants and all the leftwing
audience loves her for it. She can't do
the same when it comes to the skin of
the of Lupita Nyongo because they will
cannibalize her. They will eat her alive
and she knows it. You think it's not
true what I'm saying? Then do it. Do the
same. Make a video dedicated to the
casting specifically of Lupita and at
this point Zaya and tell us why their
skin color is not appropriate. Cuz you
see, I can do it. I can do it all I want
because I don't pander. So I've I've
complained about things that I knew
people on the right wouldn't have liked
and I still did it. and I complain about
things and not knowing that people on
the left will call me all sorts of
things racist and this and that. And I
still do it because I don't care. I have
no one to control my words and my
thoughts. I can respect my audience
because they watch my content, but part
of that respect is I don't pander.
What you're demonstrating, I'm not
trying to attack you, okay? I'm not
trying to be disrespectful to you, but
I'm following I'm giving you an honest
critique here. You can prove me wrong
anytime. complain the same way about
Lupita Nyongo as you have about the
white skin of the actors, then I'll be
like, I'll take it back, guys. She did
it. She did say that that was not Well,
she can't she can't do it because she'd
be eaten alive because on left-wing
circles, you have to it's like a cult.
You have a certain number of things that
are acceptable, defend minorities and
all that stuff. But one thing is not
acceptable is to complain about the
casting choice when it's a black woman.
You can't do it. or a black man, you
can't do it. She's not allowed to do it.
And so she won't. She's not free.
Because at this point then, don't
criticize any skin, but you do criticize
the white skin. You do.
>> It's not like Nolan needs big cast names
to pull people in to see any film of
his. Like, he is the name of itself. And
once again, these main characters,
exempt from the gods and the
mythological creatures, they're not
fantasy characters. They are based on
real peoples and their culture. So it
would have been nice if they looked
remotely like they lived in the
environment.
>> Exactly. The environment as the ancients
tell us does not of ancient Greece and
the Mediterranean does not make your
skin black. Does it does not turn you
into a black African.
I'm using your own words, lady of to I'm
mounting my attack to your argument
using your own words because you don't
stick to them. I agree with your
statements, but you don't because if you
did, you would complain about both
Zenaia and Lupitaongo, but you can't.
Okay, with Tmacus, I can give it to you.
Yeah, if you're a man in ancient Greece,
someone who spends a lot of time
outside, you should be tanned. I agree
with that. Although then again, spend a
few days, it needs to be contextualized,
right? because the skin can absolutely
become pale again if they are for
instance imprisoned and they don't leave
a cell whatever Penelope though Greek
women of high status absolutely should
have a white skin so there is that
Mediterranean are white we do tan
but you spend two nights at home the tan
goes away three nights at home the tan
goes away so this idea that you're
trying to push unless you have a tan
skin you can't be Mediterranean excuse
me
>> myths thus express the beliefs and
values of these subjects held by a
certain culture. In other words, a myth
is not a fantasy. It is rooted in
reality and the supernatural elements of
them are merely placeholders explaining
how reality is shaped by the real
peoples who told these stories
>> aka the Greeks
>> who did not have the archaeological or
scientific understanding of the world we
have today. Therefore, to ignore the
real significance of the Bronze Age, the
Bronze Aged peoples of the Odyssey,
their mechanical, scientific, and
aesthetic realities, their beliefs,
their modes of transport, the
limitations of their industry and
production processes, how they looked,
how they dressed, how they fought,
>> is to ignore the Odyssey entirely.
>> So, why aren't you complaining about the
race swapping then? That's exactly
ignoring how they looked,
>> isn't it?
>> How they look? How they look?
>> I mean, come on. I'm using your own
words. Let me use your words.
I agree with you, but you don't agree
with you. That's the problem.
>> And to erase its historical and cultural
significance for the benefit of oneself
at a disservice to a text to which we
owe centuries of culture and literature
>> based. Yes, exactly. That's what But
when we say this, you tell us that we
are, oh, why are you complaining? That's
You see, I agree with that statement.
History, mythology, culture should be
respected and represented as accurately
as possible. But you only draw the line
with the armor. You say that you draw
the line with the way people looked, but
then you don't. You only complain about
white skin, but you never complain about
Lupitaongo.
Why is that? Why aren't you following
your own thought process? Cuz I complain
about everything. I complain about
everything. I complain about the rim on
a shield and the the rivets if they're
not historically accurate. I want to
flip that table.
>> But I also complain about the race
swapping you only do with white skin.
Interestingly enough,
>> I need to do a whole video on my
analysis of the cast, including my own
analysis of who I would have cast in
particular roles. I think I had a better
cast choice, but you know,
>> I believe that. I truly believe anyone
would have a better casting choice. My
fruit vendor and fish mongers in Sicily
barely speak Italian. They could totally
have a better cast choice.
>> We're not going to focus on cast choices
in this video because really my main
goal with this video is to put to bed
this stupid rumor and this stupid
nonsense lies that have been spread by a
single YouTube video and potentially
also Reddit because I'm quite frank.
>> Oh no, Reddit. No, no, Reddit. Oh, she
said Reddit. She said oh gosh.
Absolutely not.
Uh, lady of the library, next time
you're going to mention Reddit on your
videos, tell me beforehand. So, I
prepared a crucifix. Thank you.
Reddit, I I still don't know why she
just won't say it's as Mongold. It's not
like It's not like any views that me or
you can't present when it comes to
talking about him is going to change his
empire. Anyways, plus I think Asongold
is based, but that's a different
situation. I mean, it's kind of
whatever. She doesn't want to say it.
She doesn't want to say it. It's causing
a lot of damage and it's making people
think that they know things that they
don't. They don't. So allow me, I'm
afraid to be extra sassy in this video.
But you know me, what I'm going to say
is I always emphasize this in my videos.
I hope that comes across is I always aim
to critique or look analytically at the
actions and things people have said
rather than the people themselves. I'm
not interested in that. I'm interested
entirely in actually the messages are
being relayed and how they're being
relayed, etc. You see, I appreciate that
because unfortunately, in my experience
with a lot of left-leaning or left-wing
creators, now they start calling you a
bigot. They call you racist. So, at
least if she's attacking the argument
for once instead of the person or try to
do character assassination. She didn't
do that, did she? She didn't talk about
that. So, she didn't even mention him. I
must, you know, I I appreciate it.
Points to you, lady of the library.
Points to you.
>> Okay.
>> I never want to mention channels or
creators. Although in this instance, it
may be quite obvious cuz they're a big
creator. But I hope they realize that
I'm just here to critique the flaws in
one's argument or the misinformation one
is spreading.
>> Given on my side of politics, there are
people that call everyone woke. I get
it. Okay. How about we attack arguments?
So that's what I'm going to do with her.
Okay. Not going to call her anything
apart from lady of the library. I guess
that one I did call a lady with a
library
>> because to anyone who has actually read
the obviously they were talking absolute
out of their bottom um in this video and
unfortunately the things that they said
would perpetuate misogynistic ideas
about women particularly in academia. So
>> I'm confused though because we're
talking about ancient Greece right? How
how do you get more misogynistic than
ancient Greeks? Just asking for a
friend. Just asking for a friend.
>> Please allow me to just pop this this
this chap in their place for just a hot
minute. Okay. but not in a critical way
at a dril. Now we have to talk about it.
So please allow me the floor to just
>> I've allowed you three times
>> decimate their sentiments. So the video
that I'm discussing was just a critique
of the trailer. It was absolutely
largely fine. I naturally agreed with
many of their takes regarding the
aesthetics of the movie. Thank you.
>> But but then the creator caught me off
guard uh by saying something about Emily
Wilson's translation of the Odyssey.
Here we go. Meat and bones of this
video. Do not click away.
>> The translation which Nolan has
apparently used when working on the
film.
>> G I wonder why.
>> So they go on to say that the the film
is based on a translation from Greek by
the British writer Emily Wilson. Yeah.
And they say the following quote. Why
exactly does this matter? Well, because
Emily Wilson just so happens to be a
hardcore progressive feminist who
specifically set out to rewrite sorry
reimagine Homer's text through a
female-coded gender critical
postmodernist lens because of course she
did. Basically stretching the very
limits of the original text to bend it
around modern sensibilities.
>> I'm just going to say a little over
exaggerated but generally true. So let's
see how she debunks this. And to that I
say, what a load of melodramatic
nonsense.
>> Melodramatic nonsense is um Yeah, I like
that.
>> Tell me you've never read a single
translation of the Odyssey without
telling me you've never read a single
translation of the Odyssey.
>> I'm interested in this claim actually
because I like kind of agree with that
statement though by Osman Gold. So uh
and I have I it's not just that I just
read the Odyssey. I grew up with it.
That's what my mom read to me. the
Odyssey, the Iliad, and the NAD as I was
growing up in Sicily. That's what I grew
up with. And then every Italian child
reads them at school. So double I'm
curious to see because she says, "If you
agree with that statement, you've never
read the Odyssey. To me, that's a
facious argument and in fact a
nonsequittor."
Kind of feels like you're trying to
undermine people's arguments. But maybe
not. Maybe she'll do a phenomenal job
and change my mind. So, why isn't Emily
Wilson a progressive feminist who's
trying to use a translation in order to
adapt it to a modern audience? Please,
>> particularly tell me you've never read
Emily Wilson's translation of the
Odyssey. How do people have the absolute
audacity to say such things about texts
they never read because it makes them
look like a real fool quite frankly? And
I can say this as someone who has read
five translations of fantasy and I've
read it at least 10 times over the past
decade. And I don't like being brutal,
but everything the person said in this
section of their video was completely
idiotic and untrue. No, Emily Wilson's
translation is not a reimagining and
it's not a retelling. It is a
translation.
>> Allow me a little pedantry if you don't
mind. I'm sure you don't. I'm sure you
don't cuz I mean you look like the
pedantic type as well just like me. You
are into the classics. Are you a trained
linguist? Because in the classes of
theory of translation which every
linguist has to go through me included
you know that a translation is never a
onetoone. Now perhaps I'm
misunderstanding what you're trying to
say here. So I'll allow for the
possibility that maybe I'm stronging you
but a translation is never a onetoone.
If you want a onetoone you have to read
it in the original language. Otherwise
it is going to be a retelling and there
is nothing you can do about that. In
fact, I if you give the same original
text to 10 different translators, they
will produce 10 different products. It's
just the way translation is, which is
why people can have their favorites.
Now, if for you, Cynthia, Emily Wilson's
translation is the best one. We'll have
to see why. But if that's the best one,
it's just your personal opinion, that's
totally fine by me. I personally don't
like it. The only thing I like about it
is the fact that she tried to stick to
the meter, poetic meter. I thought that
that was nice, but I'll have to I want
to see if she mentions it first because
if she does, then I do have something to
say about it. But we all have to be
cognizant of the fact that a translation
is a product of manipulation.
You can't leave things one to one
particularly when it comes to ancient
languages. But to be fair, even modern
languages, if I were to translate a text
from modern Japanese, a language I speak
fluently, I know I would have to make
some decisions. And those decisions are
going to be the product of my thought
process, my ideas. A different
interpretation of the same words might
be just as valid.
>> And no, Emily Wilson's translation does
not stretch and contort the mirror
material in the slightest.
>> It absolutely does. This is very strange
that you say this. No professional
translator would agree with this
statement. You do stretch the material.
You have to. In fact, now I'm going to
say it. her translation stretches it
more than others precisely because she
tried to stick to the actual original
poetic meter. Okay, it is beautiful the
fact that she can maintain a certain
written to connected to the ancient text
but that required manipulation in order
to let things stick into different
languages.
>> Now, not only is Emily Wilson more loyal
to the original than most translations
for her poetic meter alone,
>> but you see that's what I mean. First, I
disagree, but it is only the poetic
meter in fact and a couple of choices
like the fact that she refused to use
words like prostitute or [__] or [__]
which to be honest were not in the
original text. So, I do agree with Emily
when it comes to that, but I so not
using terms that weren't present. But at
the same time, I don't like what she
chose to do with it. Then I'll I'll go
deeper into this. So, I agree with the
sentiment, but not the execution.
However, the poetic meter is really the
only thing in my opinion that makes her
translation shine from a technical
standpoint. But it comes at a heavy
cost. It comes at a heavy cost. And the
reason why it comes at a heavy cost is
because ancient Greek is an extremely
condensed language where you can take
one word and encapsulate five in English
in order to represent the same meanings.
What that means is that once you're
trying to maintain the rhythm of the
poetic meter, you have to cut, you have
to transform, you have to like there is
no way around it. It's a choice
stillistic in nature, but yeah,
>> but her translation is more loyal than
say Fagel's translation for example in
so far as that she refuses to sanitize
the text.
>> In what way? And she refuses to use
terms like [__] or wh to describe Helen
of Troy like all the male translators
did because
>> why do you have to specify they're male
though? This is weird to me. The other
translators did. The m You see where I'm
coming with this? I'm not saying that
she's one of those like menhating
feminists, which are absolutely a thing.
She's not. But the language she's now
choosing makes it sound like why why do
you have to it's like when I talk to
Afroentrists and all they do is saying
oh these white do you have to specify
that we're talking about professionals
the other translators but the fact that
you feel the need to underline they were
male that's why they added the word
[__]
but the female did it better
why are you making it about gender is my
question
>> male translators than the male
translator of male translators Male
translators, male translators by male
translator. You see male translator male
translators like all the male transl the
male translator. Male translators look
at for example when the slave women in
it are killed. The ones who slept with
the suitors supporting those who were
there to marry Penelopey and steal
palace. When they are killed by Tmacus
and the loyal servants in the original
text, they are simply called those ones
kind of a them in feminine. In past
translations, authors did call them
words that are not in the original text.
Wilson restores this generic feminine
form, but again she renders it as girls.
Why? Well, as she tells us is because
she says that while previous
translations communicated a sense of
justice in the act of killing them, she
uses girls instead because want to
emphasize the brutality of the act,
giving them a human framing. It is more
correct to say girls than prostitutes.
But at this point, how about just saying
those women? What did Homer think? Did
he think that these women who betrayed
Odysius deserved to die? Okay. Well, if
the answer is yes, then you're changing
what the communicative sense written
source was to suit it for modern
sensitivities.
>> Those words are not in the original
text.
>> That's correct.
>> The male translators have put them in
there.
>> I do want to make it 100% clear, just
for clarity, that I'm not accusing you,
lady of the library, of being a misand
so we're clear. But I do want to point
out this in logical inconsistency in
your thought process specifically when
it comes to your argument against say
Asongold. You say that what Asongold
said was embarrassing, incorrect, wrong
because what he's saying generally
speaking is that Emily Wilson's
translation is wrong because she is a
feminist progressive woman who is
projecting her own ideas and politics
into the text. You say that that's out
of place. Yet that's exactly what you're
doing with the other previous male
translators. No, literally it's the
same. You are saying that the previous
translations were not as good and in
fact a few times you don't like them at
all because they are male. You specified
it 15 times by now. And because you
think they are projecting their own
politics and ideas onto the text. So
it's really the same thing in reverse.
At least the framing of the critique is
the same. Gender and political ideas
projected onto the text. There is more
records of male translators removing
things they didn't like from it or
sugarcoating or softening the air
translations of the Odyssey to appease
their contemporary audiences at the time
than there is any evidence of Emily
Wilson doing that at all. So in my
advice in the future when you're so
eager to take the opportunity to try and
take down a woman and reduce decades of
academic work in
>> it's not about taking down a woman now
you are misrepresenting Asongold's take
given Asongold is not a classicist and I
don't think that he has read the text
differently from me and you but he was
not trying to take down a woman I mean
let's let's be honest about this why did
Nolan choose that text can you with a
straight face. Tell me it's not for
politics. And if it is for politics,
which it is, I mean, Hollywood is
extremely left-wing, very progressive,
in fact, and all they do is race swap
and gender swap and push political ideas
that are absolutely contemporary and not
appropriate for the period. In fact,
they cast ethnic groups that are not
appropriate to the period. You don't
seem to have a problem with that. You
did say that you had a problem with the
white skin of the people. I I had
haven't seen you make a video about the
black skin of the people cuz you can't.
So that's what Assangold was attacking
and it's what a lot of people on the
conservative space are attacking. It's
the fact that yes, the choice is
obviously political and it's political
because that text connects well with
left-wing politics. You can't deny that.
And the fact that now you're saying,
"Oh, he's just trying to take down a
woman that's a strawman." Then you're a
very intelligent person. So you have to
know that.
>> To a misogynistic talking point to foam
at the mouth over how wokeness is
ruining the literary cannon. wokeness is
ruining the literary cannon. What are we
even talking about? That's exactly
what's h even if you could successfully
prove that this is not one of those
cases. This is wokeness ruining the
literary cannon. You cannot say
otherwise. You can say you agree with
it. You love it. You absolutely then
you'll have to defend why you love it
because honestly you can't love the
classics and the misinterpretation of
the classics at the same time. It's one
or the other. This is DI tick boxes.
This is a lie. So, do we love the truth
or no? You can race swap all the white
characters out, but do not touch the
black characters. No race swapping on
the other direction. I think it's an
awful take because it's anti-equality of
treatment of I my position don't race
swap anything black or white. You know
what Hollywood is doing
>> and all modern media perhaps actually
read the text that you're so eager to
defend before spewing nonsense and
fanning the flames for other uneducated
womenhating people in your comment
section to feel justified in their
disdain for educated women and anyone of
a marginalized status.
>> Do you guys think that that applies to
me? It's just a question because of
course she's talking about Asongold. I
don't think Asongold hates women. I
don't think as gold aids hates people of
marginalized status and I think that
this is very disrespectful. You are in
fact a lady of the of the if you notice
for instance that doesn't apply to me
and yet I agree with him. So how do you
reconcile? It's either I'm a liar and in
fact I hate all marginalized groups.
Okay. Or you will have to reconcile that
how is it possible that me I don't hate
women and I don't hate marginalized
groups. Why do I agree with him first?
Second, and in fact it's defamatory in
nature towards Asmongold. Does he hate
people of marginalized status? Or is he
fed up with people calling him a racist
to a point he has accepted the title?
This whole thing that you guys say
people of marginalized status, you can
be a mar, you want to cast someone
marginalized status, cast Michelangelo.
Michelangelo was quite obviously
homosexual. You want to cast a gay man,
cast him. Don't turn a straight man gay,
which is what people do. Don't change
the facts of history. Don't tell me that
the Vikings, not her, but I'm saying the
left in general. Don't tell us that the
Vikings were transgender. It's nonsense.
What is, in fact, I'm going to ask you
this directly since you're into the
classics, you're into history, I
imagine. What do you think of Emperor
Elagabalus?
Was he transgender?
>> So, the real contention here is actually
over the words, the ancient Greek word
konopes, which
>> dogface
>> translates to dogface. And when using
this term dog phase, the vast majority
of male translators have always said
[__] or [__] But Emily Wilson doesn't
use that. She uses the term dogface. And
in doing so, she is more accurate, not
less accurate, and more honest to the
original translators than the male
translators have been.
>> I love that she keeps saying the male
translators.
I'm just Okay, pulling your leg a little
bit. We'll circle back to the [__]
[__] situation because there is
something that she did and for some
reason you're not mentioning it. So I'm
going to have to discuss it and then I
want to see what you think about the
term slave because that's when she
modified the test in fact a lot. So it's
either you're not going to cover it or
if you are going to cover it that's
going to be really difficult to defend
intellectually.
>> You see male translators have more often
than not casually slipped in
misogynistic terms into the text with
their translation. Again, we're talking
ancient Greece here, right?
>> That weren't there in the original. And
this is emphasized by the fact that they
don't call Agamemnon a [__] or a [__]
But you know what?
They totally should have. Oh, that would
have been glorious. Could you imagine
Achilles going to Agamenon and saying,
"Game, you're my [__] You're my
bitch." And Agamenon goes, "What are you
on about? Shut up, [__] Get dressed
for battle, [__]
I'm now going to petition for the in.
She's right. Right. We need equality.
Okay. So, if we're calling Helen of Troy
a [__] we should totally call Agamenon
a I'm for it. I'm all for it. Next
translation, I want Agamenon to be my
[__] That's how it's going to be.
That's what I think. Thank you. Please.
Despite the ancient Greek word konopis
being employed against him by Achilles,
the same word that they then chose to
translate into [__] when dealing with
Helen. Now Emily Wilson doesn't do that
not because she was catering to modern
woke sensibilities, but because she was
being academically honest and thorough
and loyal to the text.
>> Right? But that's not the reason why she
then introduced the word slave when it
wasn't present in the original text. And
I have an interview that demonstrates
why she did it. and it wasn't for
academic honesty. When it comes to the
slaves, the Odyssey is full of all sorts
of servants, house servants, slaves of
many types. It is a fact that by
choosing to call them all slaves
differently from the text, which instead
specifies the exact profession that
these slaves had, she flattens all of
it. In the original Odyssey, Homer uses
the Greek term that properly translate a
slave only a couple of times. He prefers
to use the moss and the moy which we may
translate as domestics or household
servants. We know that these were people
who had been deprived of their freedom,
prisoners of war and whatnot. And they
were called this because they were
property of the household from the point
of view of the Greeks. In any case, this
is different from the simple term for
slave. That could be someone who breaks
stones, someone who plows the land,
another type of slave. Instead, the
Odyssey tells us what these people do.
the armory keeper, the swine herd, the
hallkeeper, the domestic servant, the
one who brings food, a female attendant,
household woman, maid servant, nurse,
housekeeper, herdsman, etc. Wilson often
foregrounds the fact that this person is
enslaved by using slave or slave girl,
but removing the information that was
presented from the original text. Just
to give you two ideas, Urica is not just
genetically a slave. She's Odicius old
nurse bought by Leertes, honored in the
household and entrusted with intimate
family duties. Her Greek identity shaped
by both enslavement and role. She's a
nurse, household elder and a slave
woman. Elus the swine herd is also a
slave, but his function is Ali specific.
He's not merely a slave. He's the loyal
pig herder, a manager of Adicious
livestock. And all of this is lost when
she just decides to call them all slaves
differently from Homer. This is an
incorrect form of translation from any
point of view that is professional. It
is not what the text says and it is also
a political choice. In her notes, she
specifically writes that she realizes
that using only slaves is not correct
and it flattens things because in the
American work, as we said, all of these
are different occupations, but she
wanted to emphasize the presence of
slavery in the ancient world. Why? Well,
it's a conscious political decision that
has nothing to do with the translation
of the text and not for a million years
as it has anything to do with the way
ancient Greek considered slaves, which
for them was absolutely normal. So, if
you really wanted to underline, you
could have put a little asterisk every
time you put one of these professions
and in the footnotes underline that that
was a slave, but removing it completely.
Awful translation choice. To translate
it as anything other than dogface is to
impose your modern ideas of women and
modern ideas of what an insult should
mean. So what are the ancient what what
are the ancient Greek ideas for the
average ancient Greek man? What do you
think their average ideas of women and
their role in society are? It's a direct
question for you. So if you want to I
mean I don't know if she's going to
respond to this. Maybe not. You can
respond in a comment. I'm not saying you
have to make the video if you want. More
than happy. But I'm saying what do you
think is the because I I understand what
you think that the modern average man I
guess thinks of women when they are
being misogynistic as opposed to what
what is the average overall idea of an
ancient Greek man when it comes to the
place of women in society and would you
once described that consider it
misogynistic because if the answer is
yes then isn't it misogyny anyways
>> rather than be honest and accept what
the ancient Greeks had because They had
different notions about the term which
we can never truly come to terms with
because we weren't there.
>> That's a weird way to put it. We do have
an idea what they mean. In fact, someone
who's into history, possibly
historioggraphy, ancient classics, it is
kind of a strange argument to present.
Well, you weren't there, so you can't
really know, right? That defeats the
entirety of academia then. But we do
know. We have ideas on what that term
means.
>> And there's very limited evidence.
Although this has been debated
academically for centuries and we can
genuinely agree that the term means
shamef face or shameful which we can all
agree is very different from the words
[__] and [__] And likewise Emily
Wilson doesn't sugarcoat terms like
slaves.
>> She does. Absolutely she does. I'll
prove it in a second
>> which are in the text like male
translators did. Ironically male
translators are more often than not
sanitizing their translations to cape
with the sensibilities of the time. So
words like slaves became handmaidadens.
Wilson on the other hand,
>> this is the strangest thing. At this
point, have you read the text in ancient
Greek? You said you read five
translations. Have you read it in
ancient Greek? I'll let her finish the
point and then I'll tell you why I'm
asking this question
>> the time. So words like slaves became
handmaidadens. Wilson, on the other
hand, does not sanitize the text to a
Christian gentle audience like male
translators have in the past.
>> Oh no, not the Christians. Oh, not the
Christian. Already you told me male and
I'm shaking. But Christian male
Christian. No. No. I'm not having it.
I'm not having it.
What is it with leftist? What is it with
leftists and Christianity?
>> And she doesn't impose her own modern
thinking onto the translation like male
translators have done so for centuries.
>> She does. And I'm going to be honest,
guys. I am trying to be nice, but her
continuously saying male male male male
is starting to annoy me, okay? Cuz it is
what it is. I'm trying though. I'm I
haven't insulted her, right? So, but but
she's making it hard.
Go on.
>> Ironically, people who slag off Wilson's
translation is because they haven't read
it. Whereas, if they had read it, they
would know that Wilson's translation is
one of the greatest translations in
English. subjective
>> because of its loyalty to the original
text because it feels the closest to
reading the ancient Greek in terms of
pace and poetic meter
>> only that
>> and she does all of that with such
scholarly precision and epic intensity
that it took her five to six years to
complete it alongside her thinking about
this translation for 20 years
>> to me that doesn't say anything though
because you could have if you notice
what she's arguing here and I hope I'm
trying to steal manner argument. But
what she's arguing here is that all the
male translators are biased because of
politics, Christianity, XY chromosome, I
suppose. And so they inject that in the
text, but the female translator instead,
no, she's unbiased. She's not. She's
absolutely biased. And she's you could
tell. And that's why you like her, by
the way. You love the translation more
than any other translation precisely
because she's making it so the female
characters have a pivotal role. Even
though that's not reflective of the way
Homer would have thought because you
can't convince me that a modern
left-wing woman is the closest we can
get to the way an ancient Greek author
thought. I don't believe that. Like
absolutely not.
>> Additionally, what's wonderful about
Wilson's translation is that it's
written in plain contemporary language,
which makes it one of the most
accessible and easy to read translations
out there. Yeah, she does simplify a
great deal by using a more colloquial
language, a choice that I personally
don't like. On the one hand, the rhythm
and musicality are there, but the terms
she uses within the structure are very
simple. It's easier to read, but look at
the opening. The epithet polyropos in
the classical translation is a man of
manysided cunnings or the man of many
turns, a person with many facets, a
person who does many things, a
multi-sided intelligence. She translates
it as a complicated man. I find it ugly,
but it has specific connotations,
feminist ones, negative if you will. A
translation in very poor taste. But I
want you to focus on this guys. This is
the sorry for covering disrespecting
again. Look at this. You know what I was
telling you that the complexity of
ancient and the richness of ancient
Greek words requires many many many
extra words in English and even in
Italian which is the original
translations that I've read in order to
convey the identical meaning. And in
fact, if you notice Emily Wilson's
translation is the shortest. It is the
shortest precisely because she has to
cut around in order to maintain the
rhythm because she's using a completely
different language. Now, stylistically,
this is an impressive work. I appreciate
the thought process that went into this
and the understanding of the poetic
meter. However, look at the length. Just
like any work of translation, Wilson's
translations has pros and cons. As we
said, one of the pros was the fact that
she tried to maintain the original
meter, but she still had to change it.
So, she's not reproducing Homer's meter
exactly. She's creating an English
equivalent. So, the same number of lines
as Homer, which is interesting, but not
identical. Not only that, but as
explained, this was a very demanding
choice because homeriic Greek can pack
more into a line than English can.
Princeton's write up on Wilson makes
this point directly. He says, "English
often needs more syllables to express
the same idea, while Wilson's pentameter
line has fewer syllables than Homer's
Greek." Of course, I'm not saying that
she tried to remove events, full-on
scenes, or plot points, but this cost is
real and is found at a level of texture,
repeated epithets, doubled adjectives,
particles, formulate redundancy, and
other descriptive amplifications.
Imagine, for instance, when Homer uses
two words to express the concept of
sweet, while Winson only chooses to use
one. She's cutting. Homer uses dense
phrases such as sped safely and surely.
Wilson compresses it to adapt it to the
needs of the translation into English
saying sped straight ahead. The original
is 10 times better. It is a tradeoff.
You can like it or dislike it. Look at
the length she has to have removed. It
comes at a cost. So, how can it also be
the closest to the original language?
It's the logics begin to break down.
Also, notice how different they are. And
this is once again strengthening the
original argument that we do study in
theory of translation when we go into
language learning because every
translation is a work of interpretation
and it has to modify the original core
language in order to contextualize it in
a way that makes sense in the receiving
or target language. That's how
translation works
>> and it highlights the inequalities that
were otherwise again sugarcoated or
worse completely removed by male
translators in the past.
>> They didn't remove them though. They
didn't remove them as we discussed on
the slave situation. You see, from the
perspective of the ancient Greeks, it
was absolutely normal to have slaves.
Can we agree with that? So, you call
them inequalities, but to them it was
absolutely fine. To the author of the
text and the people reading said text in
period, it was not a matter of
inequality. So, when you call them
inequality, which I agree with you, of
course, loss of freedom, I agree as a
man of this century, it's an awful
thing. But if you want to underline, you
need to create a writer's note. Add
writer's note. Don't change the text to
highlight those inequalities because
then you are applying absolutely you are
projecting your modernist understanding
onto the past. And if that's the route
we're going, then how do you justify the
translations that we currently have when
it comes to the debelico by Julio
Kaiser? Because that text constantly I
mean Julius Caesar mutilated people for
rebelling, destroyed entire villages,
annihilated and conquered civilizations.
Should we condemn and replace the words
in order to underline the utter awful
aspect of expansionistic war of a
republic of classical antiquity? Or
should we leave it as is?
>> Now I've got that off my chest, let me
return to my analysis of the latest
trailer. But before we go any further,
I'd like to take a moment to thank
today's sponsor.
>> I'll show the code on screen so people
can use it if they want. Where is it?
>> squarespace.com/ladyofthe
library to save 10%. Guys, let's go.
>> Off your first purchase of a website or
domain. I've already done a whole video
on my reaction of the first trailer
regarding my feelings towards the
difference between historical accuracy
and mythology and fantasy. I explained
that in great depth. So
>> you did you did go in great depth as to
why the skin shouldn't it was too white.
I'm waiting for the second episode on
whether why Helen's skin is too black.
>> No, I concede that this crater and I are
on opposing political positions and I
want to emphasize that purely because it
that in itself is not my issue. They
have every right to critique ways in
which they believe Hollywood may be
overdoing it in terms of political
correctness. And I will never agree with
that in many ways.
>> But it is true though. I mean, look, I
appreciate that she say, "Bro, it's your
freedom, political and whatnot." Fine.
Cool. Yeah, I appreciate that one. But
it is a fact that Hollywood is overdoing
it at this point. If you want to have
I'm sorry, I'm screaming. At this point,
if you want to have a left-wing approach
to this, you could say that you agree
with the political correctness that is
being pushed from Hollywood. I would
rather appreciate that one more and then
we can agree to disagree. But denying
it, I mean, come on. Look at why do you
think the Odyssey has chosen the
specific cast that it has? Right. Can
can we be honest about it as well? Like
because it is is DEI. It's DEI. All the
race swapping. We didn't we didn't make
that one up.
>> But that's absolutely fine. However,
where I will call people out is if they
are so blinded by their hatred of
leftwing politics that they spew
misinformation.
>> That's fine. But do you also call out
people who are blinded by their absolute
hatred of right-wing politics that they
spew misinformation? That's my question.
Because you see, I've done that. I've
done that. Contrary to what all of my
critics say on the hit piece videos that
they make about me, Metatron is
alienating his audience because of his
anti-woke content, right? But I have
done it for years now, given after the
death of Charlie Kirk, I kind of focused
a little bit more on left-wing nonsense
for obvious reasons. But then again, for
years, I debunked left, right, right,
left, left, right, right, left so much
that I looked like a complete lunatic.
Like I looked like someone who needed to
talk to a psychologist, if not a
psychiatrist at this point. On a
Tuesday, I was metawoke. On a Thursday,
I was the metach.
The people that criticize me, however,
click their channels. They debunk
conservatives, all right, all the time.
Not a single video when they debunk
someone of their own. You know who the
exception is? shoe on head, which is why
I like her very much. She debunks her
own. Just saying.
>> I shan repeat the foundations of my
thoughts here, although we will see many
disappointing elements from that trailer
repeated in this trailer. I mean, my
initial understanding of the trailer is
that it is incredibly dull. It's
terribly dull. There is nothing exciting
about this. For such an exciting story,
the trailer is not selling it to me at
all. And also, I agree with other
people. The accents were initially a
shock to me. I wasn't expecting Nolan to
enforce such a pronounced American
accent upon his cast. You know, I
suppose it's nice maybe to break away
from the typical white voice of power
employed by most
>> Oh my gosh. White voice of power, guys.
I don't know how to do it. I don't know
how to do it. I don't know how to not
cringe when I watch leftwing creators.
What do I do? What do I do? Because I
want to be open-minded. I want to listen
to people with different opinions.
Opinions. What the heck is White Voice
of Power though?
What do we need then? Black power
voices.
What?
How do you combat?
White voice of power and everybody
clapped in their community.
>> Hollywood historical films, i.e. the
British RP. Though my main gripe there
is that if you're going to give the
cast, you know, American accents, don't
make Dissas have a Boston accent because
we all know Ithaca is in New York.
Really? I can understand why the
American accent felt a little
>> both the Boston accent and the New York
accent traditionally are non-rotic
though. So if you really want to make
that distinction, it should be given a
California accent. Then
>> little bit jarring to a lot of us. I
think we've become more comfortable with
historical films set in ancient Europe
being given a British RP accent because
if the film is in English
>> or cochnney to be honest, I've heard the
Romans being like, "Oh, the line right."
I've heard the Romans speak like that. I
guess it depends
>> obviously because British accents feel
closer to the rest of Europe
geographically and thus by default feels
more fitting of a European story line
than an American accent does.
>> Which is kind of strange if you think
about it because in the Middle Ages, you
know how again normally in general the
British accent meaning English accent in
this case because I mean a Scottish
accent is British accent just as much as
an English accent is a British accent.
Regardless, when we think of the
stereotype RP, received pronunciation is
a non-rotic accent. As you can notice,
she doesn't pronounce the R at the end
of words or in between consonants. But
the reality is that in the Middle Ages,
people in England did. So, the accent
was rotic a bit like you could imagine
how a Bristolian accent from like the
countryside. So, they sound English, but
they do say water instead of water. So,
believe it or not, the fact that
American accents, at least general
American, do have the rotic component
makes it closer to the way people spoke
in period.
>> Though, that does bring me on to the
daddy issues, which has got everyone
talking about. So, a very notable clip
in this trailer is Antinois, played by
Robert Patterson, is confronting Tmicus,
who is played by
>> Spider-Man. I can't remember his name.
And then Robert Patterson's character,
Antoninois, tells Tmicus, "Oh, you're
just a boy pining for his daddy." Uh, to
which then Tmicus taught, "Uh, my dad is
on his way home." Everyone, including
myself, felt that was incredibly
strange. Now, here I am again to defend.
Wilson's translation does not use the
word dad or daddy at all. He uses the
word father not just because it's the
formality of Tmicus being a prince um of
Ithaca, but it's also because it's a
translation of the word pater. Uh he
does not use any more informal words
like
>> strange you should pronounce it like
that, but whatever.
>> Papa or ta uh talking about his daddy.
It's always about his father. So Noden's
employment of dad and daddy compounded
with his choice of Adysius yelling,
"Let's go uh to his army of men." Yeah.
Um it just seemed incredibly modern. And
>> finally, we agree on something. Look at
that. Me I'm agreeing with Lady of the
Library. Let's go.
>> Out of place for a king. Um although I
would argue that Adysius, you know,
doesn't really give off the uh sticking
to the royal protocol vibes in any shape
or form uh throughout the Odyssey.
However, with American accents and the
colloquial modern dialogue, uh that we
have briefly heard so far, it is giving
more ancient Avengers vibes, uh and
which is not what a lot of us wanted in
an Odyssey film. I know a lot of us have
really been craving an Odyssey film, but
we're not denied it. I want to talk
about The Return because that came out
in 2024 and that is a glorious retelling
of the Odyssey. And yes, there is a mix
of accents in this film as well, but
everything's also played down. So if
there is an American accent or there is
an English accent, they're not very
pronounced and they're also Greek
accents scattered throughout creating a
more Mediterranean bubble for the film.
And Fines who plays Adysius is
brilliant. He looks apart. He is the
part. He's exactly how I imagined this.
>> Do you think I am agreeing with her but
the problem is that she is limit
differently from me. I say whatever I
want whenever I want. don't even care if
it clashes with my audience. All respect
to you guys, but you know me. I think
the highest form of respect for your
audience is ought to not pander to them
cuz if I pander, I'm not telling you the
truth. I'm just telling you what you
want to hear. So, she can't do that,
though. So, I'm just going to see this.
Let's see. Let's see.
Is this a good representation of
Achilles? Let me know in the comments.
Lady of the library, please. What do you
think of this? Is this how you imagine
Achilles? Is it? And um is this how you
imagine Helen of Troy? Is it? Because
you know I agree with you. I also agree
that the Punisher is not a good
representation of Manelos. I can say it
totally should have been a redhead by
the way, but whatever. But I also say it
when it's black people. A lot of
left-wingers don't. That's where they
draw the line because they know they
can't or she'll be cannibalized by her
audience. She can't do it. She can't say
it.
So, um what are we doing here? If you
notice, she's very intelligently, but in
a way a little deceptively, walking
across the lines of what she knows she
can get. She can complain about white
skin. She can complain about the accent.
She can complain about the armor, but
there are things she is not allowed to
complain from a left-wing politics
standpoint. And she won't
she won't
>> to be at this stage of life. And also,
it's a really colorful film without
taking away any of the severity of the
story line. It actually looks as though
it was filmed in the Mediterranean. It
and but also it's gritty. Oh, it's
beautiful. I love it. I love it so much.
The tension is stunning. And I think
what gets me frustrated is that the news
of Nolan's Odyssey came out around the
time that
>> I noticed you speak a lot about the
Mediterranean, which is where I was
brought up. Have you ever been? Because
um this is a genuine question. I'm not
trying to trick you, but you do say you
do have this point, this position that
why are you talking about the Odyssey if
you haven't read it? I have you been to
the Mediterranean or have you only seen
pictures? And if the answer is yes, then
great. But I think as a Mediterranean
man, I do have that question for you.
>> The return was released, so it
completely overshadowed The Return, but
trust me, if you watch The Return, it
looks and feels far more authentic from
the costumes to the look of the people.
finds looks as though he's actually seen
the sun like he's been stuck in the
Mediterranean Sea traveling it for like
basically 20 years.
>> So she's going again into the oh white
skin, white skin. I would like to
underline though I was again
Mediterranean white. We do tan
but you spend two nights at home the tan
goes away. Three nights at home the tan
goes away.
So this idea that you're trying to push,
unless you have a tan skin, you can't be
Mediterranean. Excuse me. I am darker
than an Irish man or a Germanic from
Scandinavia.
Sure. But then again,
>> uh unlike Damon, who looks like he
hasn't seen the sun in 20 years. And
what I can see from the trailers and
then also the return is that the
difference between these two films thus
far is that The Return isn't an action
film and it's not trying to be one. is
not trying to tap into the hero trope of
the epic return because with all due
respect, the Odyssey isn't like that.
Like yes, on the basis of it, it is an
epic and it is a return, but it's not
like Avengers Endgame Hollywood idea of
epic. The Odyssey's very quiet like the
Odyssey's movements are incredibly slow
and calculated and that's emphasized
particularly when he returns to Ithaca.
Odysius is a man of many turns. He isn't
Achilles. He isn't action man charging
forward into battle. If Nolan truly
wanted that kind of battle scene, he
should have really gone for the Iliad
instead because Adysius and the Odyssey
isn't. You know, Adysius by this stage
of life, he's basically a pirate and
he's cunning. He's aged and he's the
brains behind everything. You know, he
was the chief architect of the Trojan
horse. He comes up with the idea. He is
the reason that Troy finally fell. You
know, the Greek army used brute force
for a decade and they didn't get
anywhere. But it's only when Adysius
comes up with his plan, which is
calculated and quiet, that Troy finally
falls. But the scenes that we've seen so
far in Nolan's Odyssey have been all
focused on action. True.
>> When really the violence of Adysius that
erupts at the end of the Odyssey comes a
bit as a shock. You know, it's a very
slow build. It's like winter being slow.
I I will say that I mean this is a
trailer, okay? So we don't know if maybe
the he showed the action moments on the
trailer which makes it sound makes it
look like I agree with her like oh it's
going to be a action packed but maybe
won't be in the final product. So that
one is one thing. See, when people tell
me, "Oh, you're criticizing. You haven't
even watched it, right?" But I know that
Helen of Troy is Helen of Congo right
now. Like I don't need to watch the
movie to criticize that choice. Just
like I don't need to watch the movie to
criticize like she's doing. Oh, they're
using Matt Damon. I I would have been
better to cast a Greek actor. To which I
agree as well. Okay. I'm not I don't
just complain about the black actors. I
complain about every actor that I don't
feel I I wish they were all Greek.
That's what I've said the entire time.
But when it comes to the action, who
knows? We we'll have to we'll have to
wait for that.
>> And slowly heated for years and years
and years and then suddenly it's at
boiling point and it's spewing and it's
gory and it's violent and it's really
intense because we've seen a pretty damn
calm man until that point. Now, how can
you build up to that climax in Nolan's
Odyssey when it's evidently forefronting
battle and action hero montages over the
subtlety of both Adysius and Penelopey's
very slow building plans? And speaking
of battles, there's a lot more armor in
this film than I expected to see. I
already talked about my ideas on the
Batman armor and Adysius's armor already
in the last video, but in this recent
trailer, we see new armor. We have these
armor Oh gosh. Oh no. I thought I was I
thought I was done with the giants. Come
on. Come on now.
Give me a break.
>> But men in a forest whom I'm going to
guess are the Lonians. Uh the men eating
giants in the Odyssey. I don't know who
else they can be. I could be completely
wrong there. No, I think you're right.
If they are the life draggonians,
putting them in armor is just a bit
jarring really because
>> and and the century of that armor. Can
we talk about that?
>> They no longer feel like mythological
monsters. They just feel like any other
army of men
>> from the 16th century though.
>> Uh let's talk about the actual silver
armor itself because obviously steel did
exist in Bronze Age Greece. Even though
it's Bronze Age, it did exist. But as
you can tell from the name, it was
exceptionally rare. Uh it was more of a
novelty that was produced accidentally
by smelting iron ore. Um and that didn't
exist enough. You know, there weren't
enough accidents to to have made the
quantities to create thousands of pieces
of armor. So again, the armor looks
anacronistic here. Though again, playing
devil's advocate, perhaps that's what he
was going for. You know, perhaps the
mythical
>> you can't you can't you you literally
there is no way to justify that choice.
I'm sorry. No way. No way. It's awful.
It's terrible. It's Meccas. It's
nothing. There's no way to justify the
late 16th century Italian barbuts. Just
don't just just don't just don't logical
element of these creatures for Nolan is
their employment of steel and their
access to it. I know it's it's tenuous.
Um but maybe that signals their
mythological status even though it would
be incredibly subtle uh and not quite so
obvious to the majority of people. And
again looking at them just aesthetically
not analyzing it very deeply it looks
medieval from a first
>> it looks like [__]
>> glance and I'm not sure if that's
something a Nolan will play with in this
film are they all time traveling is that
why you know we can see Batman armor
that's being clearly
>> oh that's why okay he's from Queens no
that's Spider-Man
>> printed or medieval style
>> steel armor in another scene I'm not I'm
not really sure the So, Agamemnon uh
teleported from Gotham City. You heard
it here first, guys.
>> With this idea that I'm throwing out
there hypothetically is that yes,
medieval looking armor would look very
mythical and magical to a bronze age
Greek, but in a film for a modern
audience, it just looks like a mismash
of really strange historical time
pieces,
>> aka [__]
>> We have Viking ships, we have 3D printed
armor, we have steel medieval armor. It
is like a prop.
>> And for me personally, I would want to
make the monsters look like their
powers. You know, nothing about these
men, if they are the Lonians, scream men
eating giants to me, you know. I'd give
them like big mouths and teeth, you
know. But maybe that's what's hiding
under their helmets. But still, it's
just not giving me mythological
monsters. But they may not be the
lifeians. That's just me throwing. Okay,
but who the heck are they then?
>> Seriously
>> out ideas. I can't think what they are
in general. You know, we obviously see
the Cyclops a little bit in both
trailers, but nothing about this is
screaming luscious mythology. You know
what we've seen from, I think, Cersei's
Island. It's bland. It's like a bland
desert. There is nothing on there. It
looks like uh a new installment of the
June film series, like June part 7 BCE.
>> That is Yeah. Oh my gosh. Of course she
uses BC.
Yeah, I mean good idea. June part 7 BC.
I'm telling you that's a actually very
good one. I I love the Photoshop here.
Did a fantastic job. You know what they
should have done? If we're going to talk
about photoshopping, just get and she
will appreciate I think she probably
hate me for everything else I said, but
she might appreciate this one. They
should have made the sea wine dark in
color. Give it a little purple. And for
someone who did was brought up in a
Mediterranean island, it does look like
that. Sometimes it actually looks like
wine.
It's rare and you need to hit it at the
right time of day, but it does happen.
Saw it with my own eyes.
>> And perhaps when we see the actual film,
the the scenes in the film will be more
filled out than that, but my god, if
that's what it looks like, poor goddess.
Living there in such a bland wasteland
is truly a punishment for anyone. And of
course, again, biggest gripe of my life,
bloody monochrome statues. We see
Adysius cutting off the head of a bloody
monochrome
>> should be completely painted. She's
right. Polychrommy is a characteristic
of Mediterranean classical
>> statatury and architectural buildings as
well. Everything was in color
>> statue instead of the beautiful
polychrome that it should have been
because heaven forbid Hollywood accepts
that the ancient world had a
personality. True. It's not garish just
because it doesn't match the elitist
maturity associated with the marbles
adorning the British Museum. They had
color once upon a time. Give them paint,
guild them, dress them in garments and
cloth like they had, you know, that's
what it looked like.
>> That's true.
>> I mean, the only highlight of the
trailer was the baby Argos, the sweetest
little bean in all of ancient mythology.
And if Nolan creates a film where the
audience doesn't sob their hearts out at
his death, then that will be proof that
he has no idea about the Odyssey because
no one can even read that passage
without crying. And I'd comment more on
Penelope and Tmacovs. But really,
there's not much to say. They all look
incredibly bland, and I can tell that
despite the Botox paralyzing her
forehead, that Anne Hathaway is really
giving it her all. But aside from that,
>> you know, I agree with that. It's
terrible. The Botox is terrible. I'm
surprised she says that though. I mean,
we agree, lady of the of the library,
but isn't that like a woman's
independence to be able to do what she
wants and feel the Botox and the lips
and the and this and the forehead? I
mean, I'm surprised you say that, but
great, we agree on that. What What's
your opinion on uh the septum rings
then? I wonder if we agree on that one,
too.
>> You know, they just it looks so blah. If
the casting is true, in my opinion,
Nolan's missed lots of opportunities to
actually have a really interesting
diverse cast.
>> Why diverse? It needs to be Greek. Why
does it have to be diverse only when
it's European, Mediterranean at this
point? Cultures. Why don't we I don't
want a diverse cast. I want a Greek
looking cast. Not diverse. It doesn't
need to be diverse. Why? And by the way,
where are the Asians at this point? Why
isn't there a a Korean actor that's
disrespectful to Koreans? No, we don't
need a diverse cast for this just as
much as we don't need a diverse cast for
Shakazulu. Because for Shakazulu, the
cast needs to be all black except for
the British soldiers when you do the
battle. Then you need British guys.
That's how it works. Because if we want
to do a diverse cast for that story,
then Shakazulu is going to be played by
a blonde guy. Then you've got half the
tribe. You've got some people are
Mongolian, some people are English, some
people are German. You don't understand
why is is the Zulu played by a German
guy, but then the English guy is played
by an Asian. I mean, it's a mess, isn't
it? But that's never going to happen
because they never want they never want
diversity on stories that aren't white.
>> He's done it in the really backwards
way. He's done it in a rage baty way
when his here's spoiler for my
discussion. I think Lupita Nyongo would
have been a better Penelope than Anne
Hatheraway.
>> I'm confused. Lup. Okay.
Lup.
How about we don't race swap? How about
that? I mean, you complained literally
about the white skin. It's too white.
Too white.
But
but Lupita Nionga will be a good
Penelopey. Why? Why on green planet
Earth can you say this with a straight
face without being virtual signaling?
It's It's disrespectful to the Greeks.
You say you love the Greek classics. Do
you love the Greek people?
They can't all possibly be MAGA in
Greece, right?
And yet there are a lot of Greeks that
are offended by this. What about Greek
representation? What about Greek
representation? I swear I don't know
what to do. I keep ordering in Greek
food to support the local Greek
community here of immigrants from Greece
because I don't know what else to do. I
make videos to defend them and I eat
Greek food. Why doesn't anyone care
about the Greeks? because they're
European. Cuz they're southern Europeans
like me. So, we're not one of those
oppressed minorities that you so
strongly and bravely defend. Yeah. I'll
never understand this. Like, it's the
I don't know. Isn't then better to say,
"Guys, don't rewap anyone. If it's a
black historical character, keep him
black.
And if it's white, keep him white."
>> You could have swapped those two roles
over and it would have made been a
better Penelope than Anne Hatheraway.
You could have swapped those two roles
over and it would have made a far more
interesting discussion, particularly
regarding Helen of Troy and Penelopey
being opposites of each other. You know,
the loyal wife versus the straying wife.
They are perceived as complete
opposites. I don't know what he's doing
by making Helena Troy and Clive Tinestra
look identical.
>> See, do you see how she tiptoes? She
hasn't mentioned once that Helen of Troy
is black.
She can't mention it. her audience won't
forgive it. She has to pretend it's not
even a thing. It didn't happen. No, I'm
discussing the role, the personalities,
everything, but and yet she does not use
the same functions when it comes to the
skin of the white actors. You'll have to
explain this inconsistency of thought.
Lady of the library, here is my question
for you since you won't say it to
yourself. What is your opinion on the
casting of a black woman, Lupita Nyongo,
for Helen of Troy/Helen of Sparta? What
do you think of that casting choice? Do
you think that that's an appropriate
casting? And if so, how do you then
justify your personal liking of the one
translation that you allegedly consider
to be the best one because you say it's
the most faithful to the original works?
Shouldn't you then want to be faithful
when it comes to the casting as well?
Shouldn't we get a Greek woman? You
can't say that you want respect for the
original works and words of the
ancients, but then you have zero
problems with the casting of a black
woman for a woman who wasn't black in
the original works. It's one or the
other. They're mutually exclusive
>> because that means there are two faces
that could have launched a thousand
ships. I don't think that's really the
point. I don't know. I have to write
more about it. But they could have been
way better choices that would have made
for a more interesting cast.
>> Tell me about it. that would have
channeled a lot of misconceptions about
ancient Greece, how diverse ancient
Greece was, what the people were like.
Um, and he's just missed all those
opportunities for a really
>> define uh diverse in the concept of
ancient Greece.
>> Cheapl looking cast and a cheap looking
film thus far. Obviously, these are just
trailers. I could be proven completely
wrong like I was with Withering Heights.
It could be a really interesting film in
its own way.
>> I strongly doubt it.
>> I don't know what he's doing. So, these
just my initial thoughts. Yeah, what is
he doing is exactly my question.
>> But if you like me to talk about my cast
ideas and what I think Nolan may have
missed the opportunity to do with the
cast, please let me know. I'm happy to
do that video.
>> Yes. And what I'm expecting, but you
could prove me wrong. You will not
mention black skin.
Even if you make a dedicated video, you
won't. Or if you will, you will say, I
don't really like the casting of Lupita
Niongo for this role because of
personality, the message, the idea, the
linguistic stratification of will it's
like I don't know what it is. At least
say it. Say you have no problems with
race swapping when it's black on white.
You do have a problem if it's white on
black. At least at least say it. If
that's your position, say it. So then we
can we know we can agree to disagree. It
will be a very difficult position to
defend if we're talking equality of
treatment. But at least it's a sincere
position because this idea that you guys
and when I say you guys, I mean
left-wing people, leftwing people. this
thing that you that you have to pretend
it's not happening or you have to be
like, "Oh, I don't even see it." and
stuff like that. I'm not trying to straw
man her, but she did not address it
once. In two videos, she complained
about the white skin. She didn't say a
word about a black casting, though.
>> I'm not going to lean into rage baiting
stuff because with all due respect, a
lot of people are all but hurt over
nothing. Like, I'm sorry to say that the
ancient world was far more diverse than
you realize it was. I'm not going to
cater to those sensibilities. The irony.
>> It's Yeah. Okay. Those sensibilities and
I tried to be nice. I tried to be nice.
Do you have a problem with people race
swapping someone who is black into
white? If you do, are those silly
sensibilities? Are you okay with taking
someone who is historically Asian and
turn him into a blonde Aryan type? Are
those silly sensitivities? These are not
This is our culture. This is our
history. Okay, you're British. I'm
Mediterranean. This is my side of the
world. We do not want people to race
swap us. The Romans were diverse. We
know exactly what an Italian Roman
looked like. We know exactly what a what
the average Greek imperial looked like.
You will not gaslight us into thinking
that I don't know. There were 30% were
black, 30% were white, 30% were Asian.
The remaining 10% were from the Middle
East. That's not how ancient Greece was.
There were a European people. I'm not
denying that there were black people
living in the empire of Rome or within
within Greece, but come on. I I just
can't stand it, guys. I just can't stand
it. Like, I'm trying to be nice. The
woman, I'm trying to be nice, but she
defeats her own arguments with these
kind of left-wing virtual signaling
nonsense. So, we are all stupid and we
are all below you at this point when we
complain about the race whopping and the
deletion of our history and culture. No,
we're not.
You can think we're stupid. We're still
going to do it. We're still going to say
it because it's unilateral. You would
never allow this if it was the other way
around, which it has been. And I've
attacked it. Oh, but I'm alienating my
audience for calling for equality or
treatment for all races. I'm alienating
my audience. I'm preaching to the far
right. I guess the
>> irony that apparently NOLA is meant to
be catering to sensibilities or Emily
Wilson's translation was when the most
sensitive people out there are the ones
who haven't even read the bloody
odyssey.
>> I read it. I read it. I think the race
swapping is inappropriate. Sue me
>> in the first place. Sorry I was sassy in
this one. It really drives me nuts. So
with all that said and with all due
respect, what the is this? What material
is this made of in Bronze Age Grease?
Honestly, it looked just like leftover
material from the Batman films, which
was far too expensive to justify
discarding, but could have easily been
handed over to the Marvel Studios for
their latest Black Panther film as a
charitable gesture, and no one would
have been the wiser. And I know many
people think it looks cool, but
honestly, to me, it
>> who the heck thinks that?
>> It just looks like those garish barber
shops all over the UK, and they have
black walls and gold sinks. And unlike
the costumes of Lord of the Rings, which
is a fantasy film, this costume doesn't
look organic to the world it's part of,
you know, had it been like really dark
bronze armor with a real spine, you
know, running down the back, that would
have been cool.
>> Yeah, but why not following the you read
the classics, right? The Agamenum's
armor is described. His armor had three
different components when it comes to
the metallic aspect of it. It was made
of 42 bands of metal. Some were copper,
some were gilded bronze, and some were
darkened bronze. So, uh, or blackened
bronze. That's what it should have. We
know what it looks like. It's described.
I've got an entire dedicated video link
in the description.
>> Now, obviously, we're only talking about
a trailer. We don't know what's actually
happening. Any assumptions that I make
in this video could be entirely
explained away in the larger context of
the film. So for perhaps his armor is
divine armor, which is why it's made of
some obscure material.
>> Satanic armor, if anything, and why it's
pristine, and why it has Chad cheekbones
carved into the helmet that makes it
look like handsome Squidward is
cosplaying Greek Batman. And obviously,
we have the plumemed helmets here, which
is far from the bronze-aged armor or the
bore tusk helmet Adysius famously wears,
but I sort of accept.
>> He only wears it once, though. only once
in the text
>> that Hollywood loves a plumemed helmet
and they always pick it for aesthetic
reasons even though I still think uh
bronzeed age armor could have looked
really cool if there was just a single
>> you shouldn't it shouldn't be the dendra
though as I as I was saying first this
is too expensive for every soldier to
have it should only be for the elites
and by the time in which historical
actual bubble of a few hundred years
where the odyssey actually takes place
we should have more bands because we
already have the next evolutionary step
from the Dendra Panop,
>> but thank you as always for your
support. Uh
>> yeah, guys, I mean it's what can I tell
you? It's it is what I expected. A few
things were fair, but a lot of it was
monumentally biased in the left-wing
perception in a way that it's
indefensible.
I asked you some direct questions, lady,
of the library. Let's see if you're
going to dress